welcome back to las vegas now this one
is for the moms and future moms
southwest medical the sponsor of this
next segment is sharing the basics and
benefits of breastfeeding
chelsea welcome to the show
hi thanks for having me absolutely we
are talking breastfeeding for moms out
there so let's just get to the basics
here
how often does a child need to feed and
does it depend on the child's age or the
individual needs
yeah so it depends on the age of the
child a newborn stomach is the size of a
chickpea or a blueberry so very small by
the time they're a week old it's the
size of a strawberry and by six months
the size of an orange so when they have
that smaller stomach size they need to
eat less amounts more frequently so
sometimes newborns feed more than 12
times a day
um in order to compensate for that what
are the benefits of breastfeeding
because obviously you know it there are
nutrients that they get from doing this
right
oh absolutely so there's benefits for
baby mom and families when it comes to
breastfeeding benefits for baby is
breastfeeding actually provides
protective antibodies via passive
immunity that's that immunity that mom
gives the baby through the breast milk
so it creates a stronger immune system
for the infant
it decreases the risk of sids which is
sudden infant death syndrome
solely breastfeeding actually reduces
the risk of sids by 50 alone and then
also
for breastfed infants it decreases your
likelihood of getting ear infections
eczema gi illnesses like celiac disease
inflammatory bowel diseases
it helps protect against leukemias and
decrease obesity and diabetes there was
a study that showed that infants that
were solely formula fed for the first
six months of life were two and a half
times more likely to be obese at two
years old compared to infants that were
strictly breastfed
benefits for mom
it decreases risk of postpartum
hemorrhage it helps contract the uterus
more quickly back to pre-pregnancy size
it's awesome weight loss especially that
baby weight that moms gain and it helps
reduce breast and ovarian cancer and
then for the families let's face it it's
free breast milk is free and formula is
expensive and it can be very cumbersome
to families that may not qualify for wic
we just talked about the benefits of
breastfeeding but what about if a mom
needs to avoid it why is that
the major exemption to breastfeeding is
when it comes to medications some
medications go through the breast milk
to the infant and can be harmful so if
mom is taking any regular
over-the-counter medications other than
a prenatal vitamin
or taking any prescription medications
then they really should consult their ob
gyn or their pediatrician to make sure
that medication is safe to breastfeed
and where can mothers go to get more
information about breastfeeding and the
support they have contact your
pediatrician most pediatricians work
hand-in-hand with lactation consultants
that can be a wonderful benefit to
breastfeeding moms and then in nevada
you can also check out
nevadabreastfeeds.org
perfect well thanks chelsea we
appreciate you
thanks take care
thank you to southwest medical for
sponsoring that segment you can find
their locations across southern nevada
for more call 702 877
or visit
smalv.com we'll be right back